Vous savez, un des plaisirs intenses du voyage
et un des délices de la recherche ethnographique
est la possibilité de vivre parmi ceux
qui n'ont pas oublié les anciennes coutumes,
qui ressentent encore leur passé souffler dans le vent,
qui le touchent dans les pierres polies par la pluie,
le dégustent dans les feuilles amères des plantes.
Le fait de savoir que les Jaguar shaman voyagent toujours au-delà de la voie lactée,
ou que les mythes des anciens Inuit résonnent encore de sens,
ou bien que dans l'Himalaya,
les Bouddhistes continuent à rechercher le souffle du Dharma,
c'est se rappeler de la révélation essentielle de l'anthropologie,
et cela veut dire que le monde dans lequel nous vivons
n'existe pas dans un sens absolu,
mais est uniquement un exemple de réalité,
la conséquence d'un ensemble spécifique de choix adaptés
établis par notre lignée avec succès, il y a plusieurs générations.
Bien sûr, nous partageons tous les mêmes impératifs d'adaptation.
Nous sommes tous nés. Nous apportons nos enfants dans ce monde.
Nous procédons à des rites d'initiations.
Nous devons faire face à la séparation inexorable de la mort,
cela ne devrait donc pas nous surprendre que nous chantions, nous dansions,
nous sommes tous des artistes.
Par contre, la cadence exceptionnelle de la chanson est intéressante,
le rythme de la danse dans toutes les cultures.
Et que ce soit le Penan dans les forêts du Bornéo,
ou les acolytes Voodoo à Haïti,
ou bien les guerriers dans le désert du Kaisut au nord du Kenya,
le Curendero dans les montagnes des Andes,
ou bien un caravansérail en plein milieu du Sahara.
A propos, c'est la personne avec qui j'ai voyagé dans le désert
il y un mois,
ou effectivement, le gardien de troupeau de Yaks sur les flancs du Qomolangma,
l'Everest, la déesse du monde.
Tous ces peuples nous enseignent qu'il y a d'autres façons d'être,
d'autres façons de penser,
d'autres manières de s'orienter sur Terre.
Et ceci est une idée, si on y réfléchit,
qui ne peut que vous remplir d'espoir.
Aujourd'hui, les innombrables cultures dans le monde
constituent un tissu de vie spirituelle et culturelle
qui enveloppe la planète,
et qui est aussi important pour le bien-être de la planète
que l'est également le tissu biologique de la vie que vous connaissez en tant que biosphère.
Et vous pourriez considérer ce tissu culturel de la vie
en tant qu'ethnosphère
et vous pourriez définir l'ethnosphère
comme étant la somme globale de toutes les pensées, les rêves, les mythes,
les idées, les inspirations, les intuitions engendrées
par l'imagination humaine depuis l'aube de la conscience.
L'ethnosphère est l'héritage de l'humanité.
C'est le symbole de tout ce que nous sommes
et tout ce que nous pouvons être en tant qu'espèce dotée d'une curiosité stupéfiante.
Et lorsque la biosphère fut sérieusement érodée,
l'ethnosphère l'a été également
-- et peut-être bien plus rapidement.
Aucun biologiste, par exemple, n'oserait suggérer
que 50% ou plus de toutes les espèces ont été ou sont
à deux doigts de l'extinction parce que ce n'est tout simplement pas vrai,
et pourtant -- que le scénario le plus apocalyptique
dans le royaume de la diversité biologique --
se rapproche rarement de ce que nous considérons comme le scénario le plus optimiste
au sein de la diversité culturelle.
Et l'indicateur le plus fiable est bien sûr l'extinction du langage.
Lorsque chacun d'entre vous dans cette salle est né,
6,000 langues étaient pratiquées sur la planète.
De nos jours, une langue n'est pas uniquement un ensemble de vocabulaire
ou bien un groupe de règles de grammaire.
Une langue est une étincelle de l'esprit humain.
C'est un véhicule à travers lequel l'âme de chaque culture spécifique
entre dans le monde matériel.
Chaque langue est une ancienne forêt de l'esprit,
un partage, une pensée, un écosystème de possibilités spirituelles.
Et parmi ces 6,000 langues, alors que nous sommes à Monterey aujourd'hui,
une bonne moitié n'est plus chuchotée dans les oreilles des enfants.
Elles ne sont plus enseignées aux bébés,
ce qui veut effectivement dire qu'à moins qu'un changement ait lieu,
elles sont déjà mortes.
Comment ne pas se sentir seuls, enveloppés dans le silence,
et être le dernier de votre peuple à parler votre langue,
de n'avoir aucun moyen de transmettre la sagesse des ancêtres
ou devancer la promesse des enfants ?
Et pourtant, cette atroce fatalité est en effet le désespoir de quelqu'un
quelque part sur terre, tous les quinze jours à peu près,
parce que tous les quinze jours, un ancien meurt
et emporte les dernières syllabes avec lui dans la tombe
d'une langue ancienne.
Et je sais que certains d'entre vous disent, "Ne serait-il pas mieux ?
Le monde ne serait-il pas un meilleur endroit
si nous ne parlions qu'une seule langue ?" Et je réponds, "Bien,
cette langue sera du Yoruba. Du Cantonais.
Du Kogi."
Et vous découvrirez ce que ce serait
d'être incapable de parler sa propre langue.
Enfin, ce que je voudrais faire avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est vous emmener, en quelque sorte, faire un voyage dans l'ethnosphère --
un court voyage dans l'ethnosphère
pour tenter de vous expliquer, en fait, ce qui se perd.
Beaucoup d'entre nous oublient un peu
que lorsque je dis "des façons différentes d'être",
je veux vraiment dire des façons différentes d'être.
Prenez, par exemple, cet enfant de Barasana dans le nord-ouest de l'amazonie,
les peuples de l'anaconda
qui croient selon la mythologie, qu'ils ont remonté la rivière de lait
de l'est dans le ventre des serpents sacrés.
C'est un peuple dont l'état des connaissances
ne permet pas de faire la distinction entre la couleur bleue et verte
parce que la canopée des cieux
est égale à la canopée de la forêt
dont le peuple dépend.
Ils ont une règle de langue et de mariage particulières
qui s'appelle l'exogamie linguistique :
vous devez épouser une personne qui parle une langue différente.
Et tout ceci est la souche du passé mythologique,
cependant, il est curieux que dans ces grandes maisons
six ou sept langues sont parlées
à cause du mariage consanguin.
Vous n'entendez jamais une personne pratiquer une langue.
Ils écoutent tout simplement et puis commencent à parler.
Ou bien, une des tribus les plus fascinantes avec laquelle j'ai vécu,
les Waorani du nord-est de l'Equateur,
un peuple suprenant contacté en douceur en 1958.
En 1957, cinq missionnaires ont tenté de rentrer en contact
et ont commis une erreur cruciale.
Ils ont fait tomber du ciel
des photos brillantes, d'eux-mêmes, 8 par 10,
ce que l'on pourrait qualifier de témoignage d'amitié,
oubliant que ces peuples des forêts tropicales
n'avaient jamais rien vu en 2 dimensions de leur vie.
Ils ont ramassé ces photos tombées par terre,
ont essayé de regarder derrière le visage pour distinguer une forme, une silhouette,
n'ont rien trouvé et en ont déduit que c'était des cartes
venant du diable. Ils ont donc abattu les cinq missionnaires à coups de lance.
Mais, les Waorani n'abattaient pas seulement les étrangers.
Ils se tuaient entre eux.
54% du taux de mortalité était dû à des tueries entre eux.
Nous avons retracé la généalogie de huit générations,
et nous avons découvert deux circonstances de mort naturelle
et lorsque que nous avons obligé le peuple à en parler,
ils ont avoué qu'un des compatriotes était si vieux
qu'il est mort vieux, et nous l'avons abattu de toute façon. (Rires)
Cependant, ils avaient par la même occasion une connaissance perspicace
de la forêt, qui était stupéfiante.
Leurs chasseurs pouvaient sentir l'urine animale à 40 pas
et vous dire de quelle espèce elle provenait.
Dans les années '80, on m'avait confié une mission étonnante
lorsque mon professeur de Harvard m'a demandé
si cela m'intéressait d'aller à Haïti
pour m'infiltrer dans les sociétés secrètes,
le fondement de la force de Duvalier
et de Tonton Macoutes,
et de sécuriser le poison utilisé pour faire des zombies.
Afin de rationnaliser cette sensation bien sûr,
Il fallait que je comprenne cette remarquable foi
de Vodoun, et le Voodoo n'est pas un culte de la magie noire.
C'est au contraire, une vision métaphysique du monde.
C'est intéressant.
Si je vous demandais de citer les grandes religions du monde,
que diriez-vous ?
Le christianisme, l'islam, le bouddhisme, le judaïsme, peu importe.
Il y a toujours un continent qui est exclu,
en assumant que l'Afrique sub-Saharienne
n'avait aucune croyance religieuse. Mais, bien sûr qu'ils en avaient
et le Voodoo est simplement la distillation
de ces idées religieuses très profondes
qui surgirent lors de la tragique diaspora de l'ère de l'esclavage.
Ce qui rend le Voodoo si intéressant
c'est cette relation vivante
entre les vivants et les morts.
Les vivants donnent naissance aux esprits.
Les esprits peuvent être appelés de la Grande Eau,
répondant au rythme de la danse
afin de déplacer momentanément l'esprit des vivants,
et lors de ce bref instant radieux, l'acolyte devient le dieu.
C'est pourquoi les Voodoo disent
que "Vous les blancs vous allez a l'église et parlez de Dieu.
Nous dansons dans le temple et devenons Dieu."
Et étant possédés, l'esprit prend le contrôle,
comment pouvez-vous souffrir ?
Vous voyez donc ces démonstrations étonnantes :
Des acolytes Voodoo dans un état de trance
manipulant des charbons ardents impunément,
une démonstration plutôt surprenante des capacités avec lesquelles l'esprit
affecte le corps qui le porte
lorsqu'ils sont catalysés dans un état d'excitation extrême.
De tous les peuples avec lesquels j'ai été,
le plus extraordinaire sont les Kogi
de la Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta au nord de la Colombie.
Descendants des anciennes civilisations tyranniques
qui occupaient jadis la plaine côtière des Caraïbes de Colombie
dans le sillage de la conquête,
ce peuple s'est retiré dans un massif volcanique isolé
qui s'élève au dessus de la plaine côtière des Caraïbes.
Dans un continent tâché de sang,
ce peuple n'a jamais été conquis par les Espagnols.
A ce jour, ils sont dirigés par un clergé rituel
cependant, leur formation au clergé est plutôt extraordinaire.
Les jeunes acolytes sont enlevés à leurs familles
à l'âge de trois ou quatre ans,
ils sont séquestrés dans un monde sombre et obscur
dans des huttes de pierres aux pieds des glaciers, pendant 18 ans.
Deux périodes de neuf ans
choisies délibérément afin d'imiter les neuf mois de gestation
passés dans le ventre de leur mère naturelle,
et ils sont maintenant dans le ventre de la grande mère, métaphoriquement parlant.
Et pendant tout ce temps,
les valeurs de leur société leur sont inculquées,
valeurs qui appuient le fait que leurs prières
et seulement leurs prières conservent l'équilibre de l'univers --
ce que nous appellerions l'équilibre écologique.
Et au terme de cette stupéfiante initiation,
ils en sortent un jour
et pour la première fois dans leur vie, à l'âge de 18 ans,
ils découvrent le lever du jour. Lors de ce moment de prise de conscience lumineuse
de cette première lueur du soleil qui inonde les flancs
de ce paysage d'une beauté éblouissante,
et soudain, tout ce qu'ils apprirent de façon abstraite
est concrétisé dans une gloire sensationnelle. Puis le prêtre fait un pas en arrière
et dit, "Tu vois ? C'est vraiment comme je te l'avais décrit.
C'est aussi beau et c'est à toi de le protéger."
Ils s'appellent les frères anciens
et ils disent, nous, les jeunes frères,
sommes responsables de la destruction du monde.
Ce niveau d'intuition devient primordial.
Chaque fois que nous pensons aux peuples indigènes et au paysage,
soit nous évoquons Rousseau
et la vieille idée du bon sauvage,
une idée raciste dans sa simplicité,
ou bien, nous évoquons Thoreau
et nous disons que ce peuple est plus près de la Terre que nous le sommes.
Eh bien, les indigènes ne sont ni sentimentaux
ni affaiblis par la nostalgie.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de place pour les deux
dans les marécages paludéens des Asmat
ou dans les vents glacials du Tibet, mais ils ont, néanmoins,
à travers le temps et les rituels, fabriqué une mystique traditionnelle de la Terre
qui n'est pas basée sur le fait d'en être volontairement proche,
mais basée sur une intuition beaucoup plus subtile :
le fait que la Terre en elle-même ne puisse exister
que par le biais de la conscience humaine.
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Cela veut dire qu'un jeune enfant des Andes
a qui on a enseigné que cette montagne est un esprit Apu
qui décidera de sa destinée,
deviendra un être humain complètement différent
et aura un rapport différent avec cette ressource
ou avec cet endroit qu'aurait un jeune enfant du Montana
à qui on a enseigné qu'une montagne est un tas de pierres
prêt à être exploité.
Que ce soit la demeure d'un esprit ou un tas de minerai, est sans rapport.
La métaphore est intéressante, définissant la relation
entre l'individu et le monde naturel.
J'ai grandi dans les forêts de British Columbia
où on m'a enseigné que ces forêts existaient pour être coupées.
Cela a fait de moi un être humain différent
de mes amis les Kwakiutl
qui croient que ces forêts sont la demeure de Hukuk
et le bec courbé du ciel
et les esprits cannibales qui demeuraient au nord du monde,
esprits qu'ils devraient engager lors de leur initiation Hamatsa.
Maintenant, si vous commencez à vous faire à l'idée
que ces cultures peuvent créer des réalités différentes,
vous pourriez commencer à comprendre
certaines de leurs extraordinaires découvertes. Prenez cette plante par exemple.
C'est une photo que j'ai prise au nord-ouest de l'Amazonie en avril dernier.
C'est une ayahuasca, dont beaucoup d'entre vous ont entendu parler,
la plus puissante préparation psychoactive
du répertoire des shamans.
Ce qui rend l'ayahuasca étonnante
n'est pas simplement le potentiel pharmacologique de cette préparation,
mais son élaboration. Elle est préparée à partir de deux sources différentes.
D'un côté, il y a cette liane
qui contient une série de béta-carbolines,
harmine, harmaline, légèrement hallucinogènes.
Consommer uniquement la plante grimpante
c'est plutôt comme une fumée tel un nuage bleuté
traversant votre conscience.
Mais elle est mélangée aux feuilles d'un buisson de la famille du café
appelées Psychotria viridis.
Cette plante contenait de très puissantes tryptamines,
très semblables à la sérotonine du cerveau, dimethyltriptamine,
5-methoxydimethyltriptamine.
Si vous avez déjà vu les Yanomanö
renifler ce tabac par le nez,
cette substance qu'ils préparent à partir d'un ensemble d'espèces différentes,
contient également de la methoxidimethyltriptamine.
Avoir cette poudre remonter dans le nez
c'est comme sortir d'un canon de fusil
doublé de tableaux baroques et atterrissant sur une mer d'électricité. (Rires)
Elle ne provoque pas une déformation de la réalité ;
mais plutôt une dissolution de la réalité.
En fait, j'ai eu des discussions avec mon professeur, Richard Evan Shultes --
un homme qui a déclenché l'ère psychédélique
suite à sa découverte des champignons magiques
dans les années 1930 au Mexique.
Je soutenais le fait qu'on ne pouvait pas classer ces tryptamines
en tant qu'hallucinogène, puisqu'une fois qu'ils ont fait effet
il n'y a plus personne à la maison pour faire une hallucination. (Rires)
Par contre les tryptamines ne peuvent pas être consommées par voie orale
étant dénaturés par une enzyme
se trouvant de façon naturelle dans l'intestin de l'homme : la monoamine-oxydase.
Elles ne peuvent être consommées qu'oralement si elles sont prises en synergie
avec un autre produit chimique qui dénature la MAO.
Ce qu'il y a d'encore plus fascinant
c'est que les béta-carbolines dont est composée la liane
sont des inhibiteurs MAO d'un genre précis, nécessaires
pour augmenter l'effet de la tryptamine. Donc, nous en venons à nous poser la question.
Comment est-ce que dans une flore de 80,000 espèces de plantes astrictives,
ces gens arrivent-ils à trouver ces deux plantes sans aucun lien morphologique
qui lorsque mises en synergie de cette façon
ont créé une sorte de version biochimique
dont l'entité est plus importante que la somme des deux parties ?
Eh bien, nous employons cet euphémisme, procéder par tâtonnements,
qui est dénué de sens.
Mais lorsqu'on demande aux Indiens, ils répondent : "Les plantes nous parlent."
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Cette tribu, les Cofan, possède 17 variétés de ayahuasca,
qu'elle arrive à distinguer de loin dans la forêt,
même si à nos yeux, elles semblent être de la même espèce.
Puis, on leur demande comment ils définissent leur taxonomie
et ils vous répondent: "Je pensais que vous connaissiez les plantes.
Vous n'y connaissez rien ?". Je réponds: "Non."
En fait, vous prenez chacune des 17 variétés
par une nuit de pleine lune, et la mélodie ne sera pas la même.
Bien entendu, ce n'est pas comme ça que vous obtiendrez un doctorat de Harvard
mais c'est bien plus intéressant que de compter des étamines.
Maintenant,
(Applaudissements)
le problème-- le problème est que même ceux d'entre nous
qui compatissons avec les difficultés du peuple indigène
les considérons comme étant originaux et colorés
mais quelque peu en marge de l'histoire
alors que le vrai monde, c'est-à-dire notre monde, évolue.
A vrai dire, dans 300 ans, le 20e siècle
ne sera pas reconnu pour ses guerres
ni pour ses innovations technologiques,
mais plutôt comme une ère dans laquelle nous avons vécu
et avons soit activement adhéré ou bien passivement accepté
la destruction massive de la diversité biologique ainsi que culturelle
sur la planète. Le problème aujourd'hui n'est pas le changement.
Toutes les cultures à travers les temps
ont constamment participé à une danse
avec de nouvelles possibilités de vie.
Et le problème n'est pas la technologie elle-même.
Les Indiens Sioux n'ont pas cessé d'être des Sioux
lorsqu'ils abandonnèrent l'arc et la flèche
pas plus que les Américains n'étaient plus Américains
dès lors qu'ils abandonnèrent le cheval et la charrette.
Ce n'est pas le changement ou bien la technologie
qui menace l'intégrité de l'ethnosphère. C'est le pouvoir.
Le visage rustre de la domination.
Et lorsque vous regardez dans le monde,
vous découvrez que ce ne sont pas des cultures vouées à disparaître.
Ce sont des peuples vivants et dynamiques
emportés hors de leur existence par des courants
qui dépassent leur faculté d'adaptation.
Que ce soit le fameux déboisement
au pays des Penan --
un peuple de nomades du sud-est de l'Asie, de Sarawak --
un peuple qui vivait librement dans la forêt jusqu'à la génération précédente,
et qui sont désormais réduits à l'esclavage et la prostitution
aux bords des rivières,
où l'on peut voir que la rivière est souillée de vase
donnant l'impression d'emporter avec elle la moitié de Bornéo
vers la mer au sud de la Chine,
où les cargos japonais voguent à l'horizon
prêts à charger le bois arraché de la forêt.
Ou bien dans le cas des Yanomami,
c'est la maladie qui a fait éruption,
sur les traces de la découverte de l'or.
Par contre, si nous allons dans les montagnes du Tibet,
où je fais actuellement beaucoup de recherches,
vous verrez un aspect de la domination politique à l'état brut.
Vous savez que le génocide, l'extinction physique de tout un peuple
est condamné universellement, mais l'ethnocide,
la destruction des coutumes d'un peuple, n'est pas seulement condamné,
mais est universellement -- dans beaucoup d'endroits -- célébré
en tant que stratégie de développement.
Il est impossible de comprendre la douleur du Tibet
sans l'avoir vue à son plus bas niveau.
J'ai parcouru une fois 6,000 miles de Chengdu dans l'ouest de la Chine
par voie terrestre traversant le sud-est du Tibet vers Lhasa
avec un jeune collègue, et ce n'est que lorsque j'ai atteint Lhasa
que j'ai compris ce qui se cache derrière les statistiques
qui nous sont communiquées.
6,000 monuments sacrés réduits en poussière et en cendres.
1.2 millions de personnes tuées par les cadres
lors de la révolution culturelle.
Le père de ce jeune homme avait été affecté au Panchen Lama.
Ce qui voulait dire qu'il fut tué sur-le-champ
lors de l'invasion chinoise.
Son oncle s'enfuit dans la diaspora avec sa Sainteté
qui conduirent le peuple au Népal.
Sa mère fut emprisonnée pour le prix de --
pour avoir commis le crime d'être riche.
Il a été emmené clandestinement en prison à l'âge de deux ans
caché sous sa jupe
parce qu'elle ne supportait pas d'être sans lui.
La sœur qui effectua cet acte de bravoure
fut placée dans un camp de redressement.
Un jour, elle marcha par mégarde sur un brassard
de Mao, et suite à cette transgression,
elle fut condamnée à sept ans de travaux forcés.
La douleur du Tibet est insupportable,
cependant, l'esprit rédempteur du peuple est un aspect qu'il faut considérer.
Et pour finir, cela se résume à un choix.
Est-ce que nous souhaitons vivre dans un monde monotone monochromatique
ou bien profiter d'un monde polychromatique, fait de diversité ?
Avant de mourir, Margaret Mead, une éminente anthropologue a dit
que sa plus grande peur était qu'au fur et à mesure que nous nous dirigions vers
la vue d'un monde générique et amorphe
non seulement nous verrons l'étendue de l'imagination humaine
réduite à une modalité plus étroite de la pensée,
mais qu'un jour, nous nous réveillerons d'un rêve
en ayant oublié qu'il y avait d'autres possibilités.
Et il est modeste de se rappeler que notre espèce existe, peut-être,
depuis [150,000] ans.
La révolution Néolithique -- qui a fait apparaître l'agriculture,
moment auquel nous avons succombé au culte de la graine,
la poésie du shaman fut remplacée
par la prose du clergé,
et nous avons créé le surplus de la spécialisation hiérarchique --
n'a que 10,000 ans.
Le nouveau monde industriel tel que nous le connaissons
a tout juste 300 ans.
Cette histoire superficielle n'insinue pas
que nous détenons toutes les réponses à tous les défis
auxquels nous serons confrontés dans les futurs millénaires.
Lorsque ce mélange de cultures mondiales
doit donner une signification au fait d'être humain,
ils répondent avec 10,000 voix différentes.
C'est par le biais de cette chanson que nous redécouvrirons tous la possibilité
d'être ce que nous sommes : une espèce totalement consciente,
tout à fait consciente de garantir que tous les peuples et les jardins
trouvent un moyen de fleurir. Et il y a beaucoup d'optimisme.
Voici une photo que j'ai prise au nord de l'ile de Baffin
lorsque que j'ai été chassé le narwhal avec les Inuit,
et cet homme, Olayuk, m'a raconté une histoire magnifique sur son grand père.
Le gouvernement canadien n'a pas toujours été correct
avec le peuple Inuit et dans les années 1950,
nous les avons colonisés de force, afin d'imposer notre souveraineté.
Le grand père de cet homme à refusé de partir.
La famille s'est emparée de toutes ses armes craignant pour sa vie,
et de tous ses outils.
Vous comprenez bien que l'Inuit ne craint pas le froid,
ils en profitaient.
Les patins de leurs traîneaux étaient à l'origine faits de poissons
enveloppés dans de la peau de caribou.
Et le grand père de cet homme n'était pas intimidé par les nuits arctiques
ni par la tempête qui soufflait.
Il est simplement sorti, a baissé son pantalon en peau de phoque
et déféqua dans sa main. Lorsque ses fèces gelèrent,
il leur donna la forme d'une lame.
Il mit un jet de salive sur le tranchant du couteau de merde
et lorsqu'il finit par geler, il l'utilisa pour égorger un chien.
Il le dépouilla et improvisa un harnais,
prit la cage thoracique du chien et improvisa un traîneau,
attela un chien qui n'était pas loin,
et disparu sur les banquises de glace, le couteau de merde dans sa ceinture.
Comment s'en sortir avec rien. (Rires)
Et ceci, de plusieurs façons,
(Applaudissements)
est un exemple des ressources du peuple Inuit
et de tous les indigènes dans le monde.
En avril 1999, le gouvernement canadien
redonna aux Inuit le contrôle total
d'une superficie plus étendue que la Californie et le Texas réunis.
C'est notre nouveau pays. Il s'appelle Nunavut.
C'est un territoire indépendant. Ils contrôlent toutes les ressources minérales.
Un exemple stupéfiant de la façon dont une nation en tant qu'état
peut rechercher la restitution avec son peuple.
Et enfin, je pense qu'il est assez évident
au moins pour tous ceux d'entre nous qui avons voyagé
dans ces lointaines étendues de la planète,
de réaliser qu'elles ne sont pas éloignées du tout.
Ce sont les terres de quelqu'un.
Elles représentent les étendues de l'imagination humaine
qui remontent à l'aube du temps. Et pour nous tous,
les rêves de ces enfants, comme les rêves de nos enfants,
deviennent une partie de la géographie à l'état pur, de l'espoir.
Donc, ce que nous essayons de faire au National Geographic, finalement,
est que nous pensons que les politiciens ne feront rien.
Nous pensons que les polémiques --
(Applaudissements)
nous pensons que les polémiques sont loin d'être persuasives,
mais nous pensons que raconter des histoires peut changer le monde,
et donc, nous sommes probablement la meilleure institution de contes
au monde. Nous atteignons 35 millions de connexions à notre site web tous les mois.
156 pays subventionnent notre chaîne de télévision.
Nos magasines sont lus par des millions de personnes.
Et nous faisons des voyages
vers l'ethnosphère où nous emmenons notre public
dans des endroits de telles merveilles culturelles
qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher d'être éblouis
par ce qu'ils ont vu, et donc, espérons-le
comprendront au fur et à mesure, un par un,
la révélation primordiale de l'anthropologie :
que ce monde mérite d'exister dans toute sa diversité,
que nous pouvons trouver un moyen de vivre
dans un monde vraiment multiculturel pluraliste
où toute la sagesse de tous les peuples
peut contribuer à notre bien-être collectif.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)